[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
véhément et savant démonstratif et
comédien il n'est qu'un Jean-Pierre koff
révélé au grand public il y a 13 ans
lors du lancement de la première chaîne
cryptée française il n'a cessé de rompre
des lances contre les dégradation
portées à notre environnement
alimentaire mais ce paladin de la
Qualité France n'est pas seulement
istron qui s'amuse à balancer des
sachets de jambon plein d'eau il sait
écrire auteur d'une dizaine d'ouvrages
tempétueux et drôles destinéses à
défendre la tradition du goût il aborde
un genre nouveau avec de la vache folle
en général et de notre survie en
particulier qui paraît chez plomb ce
n'est plus un libel mais un véritable
dossier et si au passage la plume de
l'auteur a quelque peu perdu de sa verve
la gravité de la question traitée en
fournit l'explication quelle agriculture
la France s'est-elle forgée depuis un
demi-siècle le réquisitoire est
proprement terrifiant Jean-Pierre KOF
s'en prente à la fois au laxisme
syndical et paysan et à l'incompétence
technocratique le monde agricole s'est
mué en un redoutable repère de chasseurs
de prime dont l'auteur fournit le détail
et les procédures on a fait bouffer de
la farine de moutons à des vaches
herbivor et le beau métier de la terre
est devenu une profession d'assisté
démission démagogie et pour employer un
mot très Jean-Pierre koff
[Musique]
dégueulasse